[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens
écoutez moi je pense qu'ils sont
vraiment très très bien moi je l'espère
y habiter beaucoup à l'étranger
donc je peux comparer et là je trouve
qu'ils sont excellents les travaux
parisienne l'autre elle en pense quoi
comment votre frère il en pense quoi mon
frère mes amis de même avis que moi
basket
ouais je n'avais pas vu même si aulas
[Rires]
mais gustas tu as mon bébé doc et linde
ok lindo pallice latino ouakrat salle
par salle à propre votre long construite
et goûté un chez nous faire plaquer par
pierrick taper sur trois voit que je
tapais liliane le plaqué sur un stade il
était coralie sur un stade en train de
ashfaq porte food en train de manger
chaque pan de foot je suis dégoûté ça
puis ça va c'est la fille de tahiti bob
s'acheter dit qu'à toi du coup je vais
tenter ma chance à locarno et à
pierre-yves comme ça à pierrick qu'eric
s'ils regardent pierrick ça tu verras
public se le dise et phyllis derrière
toi ça y'a des lignes qui sont moins
encombré que d'autres mais après on est
toujours très serré les gens ne sont pas
agréables et son époux seal sont pas
souriant et puis rien qu'ils sont qui
reste plantée au milieu fin bon voilà on
pense quoi sommes pas à toulouse ancien
de la gabegie mba à la samp coût des
transports dans le cabrio cela donne
grave
bouillard ciao vous prenez pas votre
sort et france à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]